un joueur professionnel des fois ça
trouve acariens john alex surprenant
avait tout pour faire une belle carrière
dans le soccer professionnel dès 2007 il
signe un contrat avec l'impact de
montréal
mais les blessures à répétitions vont
avoir raison de sa passion je savais
qu'elle joue quelques années je les ai
vus de ma passion l'époque qui était le
soccer mais ça s'est arrêté trouver je
pensais que ça m'a pas trop affecté de
ne plus jouer au foot mais finalement
oui ça a été un deuil que je m'étais
fait le jeune défenseur va combattre
avec l'espoir de revenir au jeu mais
c'était peine perdue
survient alors une véritable descente
aux enfers où s'invitent l'alcool et la
drogue
alex part à la recherche de sensations
fortes qui l'avaient connu dans les
stades et qu'il avait perdu
j'ai atteint un niveau assez creux un
sens que moi je compensais d'en
compenser dans la forge ou à sauveur
c'est dans les parts et tout ça plus
dans le social un peu toxiques mais j'ai
jamais arrêté de chercher une nouvelle
passion après avoir atteint le fond
alex va reprendre sa vie en main c'est
la rencontre avec une des dernières
chapelière au québec qui va lui redonner
le goût de vivre
il faut prendre atteint ça va trouver
qu'il faut craindre atteindre trouvé une
nouvelle passion
c'est grâce au chapeau qui l'a retrouvé
les mêmes sensations que lorsqu'il joue
haut ce que c'est un peu la même presse
est que 15 je vivais de demont faute
maintenant j'en mange complètement de ce
que je fais en ce moment que j'ai
retrouvé une espèce de similitudes entre
mon sport que je précise qu'à l'époque
et maintenant ce qui peut sa secte mais
beaucoup beaucoup de similitudes en même
temps quand on demande à alex s'il
compte réaliser un tour du chapeau dans
sa nouvelle profession comme lorsqu'on
marque trois buts dans un match
la question le fait sourire mais
peut-être pas maintenant parce que
c'était champ car ma première année je
suis les chapeaux ça va très vite et je
suis déjà en train de faire décoller
avec des designers ses portes à montréal
l'oeil de plus en plus de monde qui
m'approchent on parle de plus en plus
loin le tour du chapeau peut-être dans
quelques années si si je réussis plus à
l'international
après un temps à confectionner des
chapeaux alex surprenant rachète petit à
petit l'atelier de la créatrice qui va
bientôt prendre sa retraite avec cette
fois la ferme intention de gagner son
match le match de sa vie
ce qu'ils vont devenir un choix
professionnel ou ceux qui vont performer
dans n'importe quelle demande mais c'est
déjà un passionné
[Musique]